it's our first morning in virginia and
today we're gonna be moving georgie's
stuff out
this is where we finally get to shut the
door on his past
and you know start fresh for us
but we can't move forward and get
married if he's not
being honest with me
i hope we have time to enjoy
virginia dc together we're here let's
just get this stuff done first i feel
like we can really enjoy it once we kind
of
get it done you know i mean how are we
even gonna get the stuff home
like the day we're trying to come to
virginia i find out you know
your car just got taken away like all
these little things just keep popping up
out of the blue
we need to just like come up with a plan
of action what did you professionally
telling me we could have been proactive
to find other ways
to cope or deal with things no i want to
protect you because i love you and i
don't want to tell you stuff's happening
because i don't want to stress you out i
don't want to
worry you because i don't know you have
your own issues you need to deal with
well as your fiance you can tell me
anything i don't care if it's the worst
thing in the freaking world
so then i therefore don't have to feel
threatened in a sense like why did he
wait to say that i don't have to
question those sometimes sometimes
sometimes either you're hiding or
i care about you i don't want to tell
you to freak you out
not because i'm hiding something it's
because i'm protecting you
[Music]
sometimes i don't open up about my
problems because for me to open it up is
like complaining about your problems and
i don't like to complain because
in bulgaria that's how i'm raised
complaining is weakness and
that's why i kind of keep my problems
from myself
you